which party will it be in the year 2,030
probably no longer give place 1
will definitely still exist 10th place
perhaps no longer.
the free democrats,
FDP
no longer play a major political role um,
are still raging a bit now um yes,
in the government From.
no longer play too big a role,
even if you have the
politically considered for the future um.
the party also um
yes,
it's a small party.
there was a big dispute between Nico Sam's Rott,
who has left the party
and the patron Martin Sonneborn.
it will probably still exist.
but MH.
we'll see.
pdh,
no idea
what this party here is always supposed to do.
CDU,
CSU,
which of course um a historic bank,
it will continue to be safe
hm,
I'll give it 3rd place.
ah there will be.
The Greens in any case.
the topic with the climate will come more and more,
we are starting to feel something about it and um.
the
green boom has of course stopped a bit for now
in the last months and years also uh,
since they have been in government.
but the topic we will just on
own body more and more notice.
that is why The Greens will also in the year 2,030
still play a major role.
the SPD hm.
a very very old party,
yes that is questionable.
the poll figures very weak in turn.
yet they won the last election.
it will definitely still exist.
but the
should restructure,
in my opinion.
the left one,
it won't exist anymore.
they are completely at odds um they will
resolve quasi differently
as they have done now.
maybe n new name,
new branding.
so that is most likely that it will be this party
will no longer be as we know them now.
we are already at the blatant opposite.
Alliance Sarah Wagenknecht,
freshly formed um
has many prospects of success
and she will
in any case in the year 2,030 then still give.
the AfD in turn does not.
we have experienced the piek of the AfD um
and now he also goes down,
because oh
it's really true,
the AfD works with neo-Nazis,
together with right-wing extremist
in their own ranks are right-wing extremists yes um
the silent majority has awakened and
I think it will.
this party has reached its peak.
they will probably
no longer give in the form as now in the year 2,030.
the free voters
similar to CDU,
that's such a Bavarian thing,
you'll have to explain that to me.
they will probably still exist.
what do you think about it?